I've heard stories where I read one
story online where it was a mother who
said that she was totally in favor of
all of this she was cheering it on she
was going to the rallies of the parades
and then when her kid came to her and
said that he was trans they were like no
you're not and then also they went uh oh
the the reaction that they got from the
schools from everybody was don't be a
bigot and they were like but we know our
kid our kid was never experiencing any
of these symptoms has is now just saying
these things and without any symptoms
the school is saying it's true and
that's what woke them up to hey this
thing is it's something else someone
else is going on one of the phenomenon
that or or another parallel to what was
going on with the cultural evolution in
China and today was you had red and
black identities in China if you had a
red identity you were accepted as
politically correct you might have been
a socialist maybe someday you were going
to go on and become an actual member of
the Communist Party
um and so that was one of the ways that
they segregated each other here in the
U.S now if you are a CIS a normal white
person that is not that doesn't have any
kind of
um LGBT identity you are looked at as
suspect because you possibly could be a
republican yeah you might be so
automatically just by your just by not
having any kind of protective identity
you are suspected of being the other the
bad guy and there is a way out you can
just take on any type of LGBT identity
you can be non-binary you can be some
type of polyamorous or whatever any kind
of thing that you want to take on that
gives you an LGBT identity protects you
from being accused as of being the bad
person and it's the same thing that
happened in China it is it is not new
and if I wish that more people would
recognize this and and I think that if
they did they'd be scared as crap that
was like the beginning of the social
credit score in China and now we're
seeing that in the United States and you
know I think it's funny because people
say well why don't more people run for
office and I just look at what it was
like to run and for office you know
because that's like the major social
credit score right I'm like I don't know
if I want to order for my Starbucks app
because my name is on it you know I
don't know what people will do when I go
in and I mean it is true that if you are
known for something and when does it
come to when do we get to the point
where someone walks up to you with their
cell phone and looks at you and goes
okay no they don't pass their their
social credit score is too low or the
bank looks at you and says no this
person they don't pass I mean we're
getting there I'm confident that that
has happened already it has just not
been exposed yes I agree
it it starts with
we have the ESG stuff which is behind
the scenes companies not wanting to
allow certain behaviors because it could
affect their ESG rating or whatever
Michael Knowles had this big Twitter
Thread about Anheuser-Busch that
basically they're wrapped up in this so
they'll never back down they can't back
down well okay then we need to stop
buying their products and then hopefully
this Panic just keeps dragging them down
I think with the H with HSBC downgrading
their stock that may be
that may that may that may be a a
Cascade effect but I'm also thinking
about it in terms of you know this this
new Industrial Revolution and what work
really means and how many people there
are in big cities who do literally
nothing no work nothing and they make a
lot of money
I'm comparing somebody who's say a
Tradesman
to somebody who wrote for BuzzFeed news
the person writing for BuzzFeed news did
not create anything of Merit or value to
Human Society but was getting paid a lot
more than say an apprentice Tradesman or
or something like that someone was
actually building things and fixing
things so right there you already have
the makings of social credit the fact
that you are a New Yorker of high social
status the credit was already there and
it's simply money money being given to
you for no real reason
and then you can buy things and have
access to things I was thinking about
this a few weeks ago I don't know if
social credit is going to be what people
think it is that you'll you'll pop a
phone and you'll look at the app and
you'll say a 200 oh wow you know you're
you're up there oh a seven oh yeah no no
it's gonna be money people who worked
for BuzzFeed news and vice were getting
money for being good socially upstanding
citizens they were working for these
companies and writing woke propaganda
and getting paid a lot of money to do it
getting paid more money to write woke
propaganda than to fix a toilet we need
toilets we don't need woke propaganda
the party needs well propaganda and you
are rewarded heavily with big money as
we enter this new this new Industrial
Revolution
the jobs you get are the social credit
score we are not going to need Farm
hands when we automate these jobs so
what's going to happen is the job you
get the company will get financing for
ESG the banks are going to be like
you're very woke here's financing
they'll then hire you and say we want
you to make big signs saying go
communism and you'll get paid 100 Grand
a year to do it then someone else of low
social standing who makes burgers for
instance they get less money you don't
need to have that score attached
somebody then I wonder how it is that
people can walk into these nightclubs
and just throw money around like crazy
like what job do they have I thought
about this at casinos how could there be
a guy at the craps table with three
grand like what job does he have he must
have a really powerful important job
in the future it's not going to be what
important job do you have because we're
Auto automating away a lot of the labor
it's going to be how have you helped ESG
and then you're going to get cash
net cash granted the excess yep
digital Gulag and cbdc's backing the
system so one extra security layer for
it is I don't need to assign a score to
you I just need to make sure you get
money for supporting the the the far
left cause how many people worked at
Twitter that got fired and Twitter
functions essentially the same and
actually they're changing things you
know and that's exactly it they're
getting paid ridiculous sums of money
live in San Francisco
because they're propagandists for the
machine that is your paycheck was your
social credit score if we are not tying
labor to I'm sorry uh your your income
to your labor anymore it literally used
to be like I bake bread I get paid and
we value that that was Merit Merit is
becoming your social standing look at
Instagram look at Twitter look at Tick
Tock your social status Dylan Mulvaney
produces nothing for the society but
probably makes a lot of money
Dylan Mulvaney then the combination of
social currency big following and hard
currency for while producing nothing of
value means that Del mulvani can walk
into the White House and you can't
that's social credit right there but
also a very depressed Society because
think about what those people are really
like I mean I think Dylan Mulvaney is
genuinely depressed we keep hearing that
you know he's struggled a lot or she
struggled a lot since all of this has
happened you know this is all a big
problem but it's the same with the
people it's the same with these
reporters that are these woke reporters
that are writing they they're very
depressed I mean you read the articles
well they just put an article out in
Michigan saying these reporters these
young reporters go through so much harm
and stress over having to write these
stories and then one guy says I couldn't
even I was okay with it not even being
true because it was so stressful for me
I'm like whoa but that's exactly what
you're saying they're making a lot of
money to put the message out it doesn't
matter if they're doing a good job job
they are putting the message out but
they're living miserable lives so they
may be getting a lot of money but
they're miserable what kind of a society
is that so it's a very dark one so this
is what they're trying to do they don't
want shows like this to exist because we
do very well here at timcast the daily
wire does very well and voting with your
dolls has always been a thing so
currency being some kind of social
credit has always existed but as we get
into
as we're fighting a culture war and as
we're moving into an information economy
and influencer economy this is why the
left has organized to go after sponsors
because then they can remove you from
the system and strip you of your Social
credit standing
it's all about influence you have an
Instagram account you're a pro
skateboarder let's say you got 100 000
followers you have sponsors every time
you post a picture of you drinking their
sports drink you get paid 200 bucks
someone then starts emailing that
company and says cut them off take away
their funds you're only allowed to
support our political cause if we lose
that fight you are in full-blown
communist social credit score system yep
and that's that's the goal that I I
really don't think that there's uh a
whole lot of
convincing argument that that would be
able to make me think anything different
now the the technology that we have like
we talked a little bit about fintech the
technology that we have
available to us now and the convenience
that people have gotten used to the
ability to just use your phone to do
stuff like that they're gonna make being
in the in the digital Gulag so
convenient and so comfortable that it's
gonna actually it's gonna be so alluring
and no and very few people are going to
say no I don't want to be in the you
know inside it's going to be something
that is
I mean I wonder if there will be very if
there will be anybody that would really
choose to be outside of it other than
people that are like old there would be
some Millennials maybe some gen xers
that would say no but anyone that that
hasn't been born yet or anyone that's an
infant or under five years old now they
will have they will never have known
life outside of it and the idea of
living like those old people it'll be
like the idea of living in the Stone Age
you with with AI technology where it's
at with VR technology and the neural
link chip and metaverse stuff I mean
metaverse I think is like crumbling
apart but digital digital worlds
no one's going to want to live in
reality yep you're gonna you're gonna
click the Nora link into your chip into
your port on your neck your eyes whirl
back in your head you enter this Matrix
Universe where you where you as a god of
your own reality just say generate me a
world where I'm the Dragon Warrior and
I'm Gonna Save The Princess and then it
just manifests right before your eyes
and you say I'm gonna live here instead
it's like Westworld yeah yep you get to
live in your fantasy where you can do
whatever you want why would anyone want
to leave the worlds that people are
going to create are going to be the most
horrific monstrosity because there's no
repercussions you're gonna you're gonna
have the most insane deviant crazy
self-indulgent
monstrous like it's gonna be over two
years ago because you can experience
anything you want and if reality sucks
that's gonna be more appealing oh oh no
it's gonna it's they're gonna be worse
because people are gonna be like Oh you
mean I can chop bodies up and have and
experience that and not have any kind of
vacations it is called it's called GTA
yeah exactly the fact that Grand Theft
Auto has a video game has been so
popular for several decades everybody
everybody has gotten the hooker then
beaten her to death and taken the money
back like that was the joke in GTA you
go you get the hooker you go behind the
thing you beat you and so you know like
that's the thought of the video yes
I have never played but I have I you
know when I was in college all my
friends would take me in and show me
exactly that but it's true everybody's
like look at this you can't say I'm not
right you
GTA got better and better and one of my
favorite things was if you're playing
Grand Theft Auto you can aggress upon a
pedestrian in any way that's why I'm not
saying like straight I'm saying like any
any way to make that person want to
fight you and as soon as they start
chasing you you can call the police on
your phone when the cops pull up as soon
as that other person hits you the cops
arrest that person so there's a there's
a lot of really interesting Dynamics in
Grand Theft Auto to make it fun mostly
in the past few years people have been
playing online that's what they've been
it's mostly just player versus player
mini games and stuff like that but when
we get to the point where you can put on
a headset or plug yourself into the
neuralink neural Link's gonna change the
game when we can do read write brain
computer interface and someone can plug
a cable into your brain to give you an
experience and you can actually feel in
these universes no one will ever leave
yep why why would any nobody I don't
know I cannot I get that but I also
think that there's something seen so
amazing about life that is really hard
to give up that nature that ability to
carry a child nurture a child I think
it's parenting I mean maybe it will
become uncool and it will go away but I
just can't imagine that you will give
that up
hold on here's what here's what's going
to happen you're going to apply the
women yeah you're going to apply for a
job and they're gonna say great when can
you start and you say I can start first
thing Monday morning I'm like amazing
and what's your your neural Link contact
and you're gonna say I I don't use
neural link and they're gonna say well
all of our meetings are in the metaverse
you you have to have a norling contact
and well I guess I'll get one and that's
how they get you I think a lot of people
will be inspired to start their own
thing like even with sponsors
scholarships and stuff we see companies
like daily wire sponsor themselves Tim
cast sponsor themselves with Casper
group coffee yes but like cell phones we
just all did it you're everybody said
you've got to have a cell phone how am I
supposed to get in touch with you and we
said okay we'll get one and people
people I remember saying I'm not going
to have a CIA tracking device in my
pocket now everyone's like which CIA
tracking device did you get and they get
the Apple One or the Android one and
there's something else you guys that I
want to go push or go back to what you
had said about talking about the
experience like women wouldn't do this
and Etc that is all garbage all right
the reason that's all garbage is because
your whole universe is in between your
ears
so once neuralink can figure out how to
produce the experience
it's over
I don't know about read write to a brain
that could be a long way off we're
already at the point where neuralink can
read brain signals yeah and so uh um and
they've and I thought this was going to
be used for good things like people that
can't walk that's where we're at right
now and I do think it's fantastic they
can connect nerves and give people the
ability to walk or they can do uh like
those robotic legs so you can use your
mind to move them and you can walk again
they're just gonna make walking
unnecessary
Wally got this wrong in Wally everybody
was morbidly obese floating around in
chairs it's really funny how when we
look back in time like um Demolition Man
you ever see that movie no with
Sylvester Stallone and Wesley Snipes I
think it was right
is that it was yeah so it's he's a cop
and he gets uh Frozen for like 30 years
or something goes to the Future because
he he they frame him for a crime or
something I don't know I can't remember
the story but uh he's in the future and
phone booths are Video Phone booths
isn't it really funny that back then it
was like the 90s they made this movie
and they're like what will phone boobs
be like in 30 years like they'll have
cameras in them we got rid of them all
in like the year two in like 2005 we
started getting rid of phone booths and
everyone got cell phones by 2007
everybody had a cell phone we could not
predict how it was going to play out so
right now you you get Wally where
they're like in the future everyone's
gonna be in Hover chairs eating and
morbidly obese with no bones because
they don't have to do anything uh and
and no I think you're right no one's
gonna need to walk at all we're already
the point where you can load up
mid-journey and and type in something
like
well here's what I like doing if you use
mid Journey here's my advice
if you want a photograph you type in the
photograph and then put Getty
photography because what it what it what
it does is it's trained off the internet
so all the captions for photos that look
real will say Getty photography or
something of that nature or AP news so
if you type in Donald Trump eating ice
cream Getty photography it will simulate
a Getty photograph Donald Trump
instantly you can make these things I
typed in last night Donald Trump going
Super Saiyan and got a cartoon of a
super ripped Donald Trump glowing with
energy and spiky hair I did uh Joe Biden
super ripped and got Aviator Joe Biden
all ripped flexing with the glasses on
we can do that in an instant so that
means we're a couple of years away from
being able to render a full video where
you're like make me a three minute video
of Donald Trump doing a series of
backflips on the on a gym mat and it
will render it so what's stopping you
from creating some video of a politician
that says something terrible and
changing the course of the world nothing
we can already do it with audio I I we
there's 11 Labs we I can pull it up
right now and simulate the voices of
several prominent personalities because
we've done it to prove a point I can I
can literally you know what let's let's
uh but that's the danger of having
someone like Joe Biden as president
because you never know what the people
around him would create and he has no
idea there is only the people around him
are there any laws about the AI voice
that's why they're trying to put they're
trying to make laws around this and and
what was it Italy that just made it
illegal was it Italy that just made AI
illegal I think so and and so I mean
think about it because if you have this
Manchurian Candidate if you have this
guy who really is not in there at all
and you can create something and send it
to Putin or you could send it to you
know president G and you could create a
world war or something I don't know who
knows let's let's give this one a shot
who are you doing Tudor Dixon is
fantastic I think everyone should listen
to her podcast this is Tucker Carlson
thank you and good night it's pretty
good I just typed that out right now
that's true but did he not actually say
that he did not say that
I'm sure he said it you can notice the
inflection was a little weird because
the computer doesn't know proper pacing
it's just text but you can do tricks
with commas and periods and
capitalization to make to and then
re-render it until you get the proper
inflection or you can actually just do a
couple words at a time and then edit
them together
there was a viral video of Joe Rogan
selling um
let's call it male enhancement and it
was completely fake someone AI generated
this stuff it's already happening so if
we're at that point
with virtual reality headsets we are a
few years away from you being able to
put on the headset and say uh Oculus
render me a universe a video game where
I get to be a street fighter in Street
Fighter 2 and then it will just make it
it will make that game instantly for you
and you'll be like oh cool I'm I'm Ryu
and I'm gonna do a Hadouken
who's going to want to go outside
when you can have literally already
people get addicted to mid-journey the
AI image generator because it's so much
fun but so I will I will fight back on I
know you're like no stop talking I got
you too but what about what about okay
movies where Earth is gone right they're
in space they always long for Earth they
always want to go out and be in the
grass and see the birds and I believe
there's people that will always models
have you seen the have you seen the
picture where they put the VR goggles on
the cow
but you can't smell the cow
no they gave a cow a cow virtual reality
goggles to make it think it was in a
beautiful lush green field with the sun
shining to get it to produce more yeah
make more milk look I mean I know I had
no idea I know I'm the black pill guy on
this one but the thing is like I said
everything you experience happens
between your ears your whole world all
the things that you think that you
experience in the real world they're not
they're in here and there is a real
world that we can come in contact you're
selling this pardon me you're selling
this I know you're like involved
it's not something that I'm happy about
but the truth of the matter is the the
way that we experience the world is in
our heads like we come into contact with
things and like without that's why you
can have Phantom pains and stuff like
that people lose a limb they can still
feel the pain because the experience
isn't in the limb the experience is in
your head if they can plug into your
head and make things it is there is a
human experience I believe that cannot
be given up what about the the wife who
wakes up the moment her husband dies in
battle what about the the mother who
I don't have any ability to explain
things that are Supernatural I I do
we're all already in the metaverse that
just makes me God knows if you're
actually networked in it makes sense
then that when someone dies you're like
whoa because the connection gets severed
it's like Network signal lost you know
what I mean no no it's your your heart
maybe I'm too positive but I agree with
Tudor that there are like you can't
replicate the things of Life thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time